last night that was fun did you see the
package that uh
uh the thursday night football crew cut
together of kyler murray and troy aikman
running
when they played for oklahoma that was
fantastic he's one of my favorite people
and uh it's just fantastic listening to
him and
joe buck together hall of famer troy
aikman how are you troy
i'm good rich how are you did you know
that package was coming did they hit
that in your meetings
no i didn't uh uh all i heard right
before the package rolled i heard our
producer tell
joe have some fun with us what's coming
up i haven't seen this whatever it is
and
they didn't have many highlights to
choose from i will i will tell you that
from my days at oklahoma well it gave me
a good chuckle it was great and again
it's such a great watch you and
you and j how long have you and joe call
games together now how long our 19th
year together
uh you know we did i i got into
broadcasting you know one i retired in
2000
in uh so my first year i was on the
number two crew matt mellon left and
went to become the gm
with the detroit lions and worked with
dick stockton and
daryl johnston and then the very next
year
madden left for monday night football
and they moved joe and i and chris
collinsworth into the booth we worked
together for three years
right and then uh so 19 years and then
joe and i by ourselves uh the last 16.
so it's been a long time hard to believe
and i guess i i wasn't planning on
starting this way but it might as well
just keep going here
one of the greatest moments of the
season on the broadcast was uh joe
learning that he's in the pro football
hall of fame which obviously you did
have a heads up
on that one that was so well deserved it
was just awesome troy
really was you know rich i i was not
given a heads up
i i was i was told to wear my jacket my
gold jacket because it was the 100th
anniversary of the hall of fame
there was i was told there was something
going on at halftime i thought it was
going to be david baker
doing something on behalf of the hall of
fame which ultimately he did but then it
was to
tell joe that he was going in and uh so
it was a
it was i i learned the same time that
joe did
it's pretty awesome you know i mean as
someone who gets to work with him for as
long as i have
um i i haven't taken for granted just
how talented he is i
i can't imagine there's some really good
ones as we know uh
al michael's jim nance and others over
the history of our game but
i just can't imagine anyone being more
gifted than joe
with how seamless and smooth he is doing
a ball game
troy aikman here on the rich eisen show
fresh off of calling thursday night
football with
uh joe and then you are you enjoy
calling packers colts later on this week
correct that's what you got going on
yeah yeah yeah quick turnaround for us
should be another good one you know last
night was an important ball game and
this is uh two good teams
squaring off on sunday as well yeah i
want to talk to you about that in a
second but it was an important ball game
last night troy because if seattle had
lost that game
they wouldn't have been they they would
have been uh better than 500 in this
division
by the end of the year they couldn't
have done any better than that they
would have lost both to arizona
and they would have lost 3-0 or three in
a row for the first time
in the russell wilson era but the
defense looked
much more stout than it had all year
long is uh
what to what do you attribute that do
you think troy
you know it's not what i expected um i i
did
we had seattle against the rams last
sunday and and uh they didn't play well
in the first half but in the second half
against a good offensive team in
in the rams they they held them to six
points and did a nice job and
you know then they come in against
arizona the number one offense in
football going over 400 yards a game and
and
uh they they played really well i i just
think that
the the seattle seahawks are just
trying you watch them and they just
don't really seem to know exactly what
they're going to major in on defense and
and
and they're caught in a real bind
because of the injuries they've had in
the secondary and not being able to
really get after the quarterback but
they corralled
uh tyler murray last night uh holding
him to a season low and
and rushing yards and and i think it's
just they were effective with their
blitzes and
and did a nice job if they can just get
you know the the key for seattle really
has been
if they just protect the football um and
and i know that that's cliche
and a lot of teams can say the same
thing but
it's really true about this particular
team and and when they do that
then they're really hard to beat and
offensively they can be explosive
they got back to what we know they've
been about and i know that pete carroll
when we had them going into the rams
game
he kind of you know uh
brushed aside the question i had about
whether he was comfortable with how much
they were throwing the football because
i know at his core he likes to run the
ball and
and then they had another poor outing
and russell wilson struggled and then he
made it clear this past week that he
wanted to get back to doing what they
have done for so many years and and it
paid off and i don't think that that
takes away anything from what russell
wilson has been about but
they're a better football team when
they're balanced and and
being physical and it really helps their
defense out as well and
and i think that part of it's been lost
and so i think it was good complimentary
football and
as you know rich i mean seattle
regardless of what it looks like
um this is just one of those resilient
teams that you just never can
count out and even had they have lost i
would not have been
worried about them too much because and
i understand every every games
you know a difficult game in our league
but if you look at their next four games
uh it would be a huge surprise if they
don't win the next four
so even with a loss they're looking at
ten and four
uh after the next month of the season so
now that they won they're in a great
position and they're only going to be in
a better position here in the next four
weeks so then
who is arizona and uh uh by saying that
i i mean
here's a team that if they had uh
won this game could have really taken
control of things and
needed a hail murray in order to beat
buffalo
and had an opportunity if they could
have beaten tua and miami earlier um
in the month had an opportunity to take
over first place then
are they just a team on the upswing or
do you think they can actually make some
considerable hey right here
and right now having seen them now i
think that uh i do think they're on the
upswing i mean
i do feel that they're i don't think
they're
the best they're going to be i i think
they'll continue to be better this year
but i
i think they easily could make the
playoffs don't get me wrong but
i i believe that they're probably a year
away um from
from really beginning to you know be the
team that i believe that they can be
with the personnel that they have and
defensively i like the players there
they got some young players some really
talented gifted guys
that i think are just maybe a year away
but with that being said i think tyler
murray here in the second season has
done a terrific job
uh didn't have his best game like i said
last night but they have
they have squeaked out some games it's
part of the nfl we understand that
but the last time these two teams met
the there was a
probably an improbable win for them the
way that they came back at the very end
and then one in overtime against seattle
in the game that they won another
improbable win on sunday against buffalo
the way that unfolded so uh they're
probably
about in the best case scenario where
were
where they had hoped to be as far as
their record goes they still
obviously are right in the thick of it
but i think this team's only going to
get better
and and uh and kyler murray uh i i
i'm impressed i mean when i when i watch
him he's a he's a unique player i don't
think there's anybody else like him in
our game you can point to
someone like lamar jackson but i think
when you look at the whole package of
tyler murray
uh he's outstanding and um and
and who would have guessed i mean uh the
i was talking to joe about it last night
before we went on the air and
years ago with the quarterbacks in the
college level there was still the time
when you didn't want to run your
quarterback in the nfl you're worried
about him getting hit and i said well
eventually that has to change because
the college games just not producing
pure pocket passers and and it really
has now even us
as broadcasters we don't talk anymore
about quarterbacks getting hit
you know it's just kind of part of the
deal because these guys are so athletic
and
tyler murray's been uh he's been fun to
watch yeah and how did you find him uh
talking to him cause we also saw last
night he to me he was clearly hurt
uh you were pointing that out you were
pointing that out before i even noticed
it uh because you know you are who you
are
uh he was clue he was clearly hurt he
was clearly hurt last night and so
you you saw how he was trying to perform
and fight through it in a big game uh
not come out or or not uh show any more
than he was showing but when you
you sat down i'm i'm assuming this is
the first time you saw him all year
what what'd you find when you when you
chatted with him troy
i i like him i mean he's a great
competitor i know his history i
i'm familiar with him from back when he
was playing high school football just uh
up the road here in in allen texas and
had a terrific
high school career and and then at every
level you just think that well how is
his game going to translate and it
and it has and so i've gotten to the
point rich with these guys with so many
players that when they call into
question whether or not they can make it
in the nfl
i say well you know they played if they
played a good school a big school and
they played against
great competition and they were able to
do it in college there's no reason for
me to think they can't do it in the nfl
those same players are the ones going on
to play in the nfl
but i i i like his i like his
competitiveness i like his desire to be
great
um i think the key for quarterbacks
is can they get locked in every week i
mean there's guys who come off the bench
and they have good
games or there's quarterbacks who step
in and will play well for two or three
weeks but
the aaron rodgers the tom brady's drew
brees
you know these type quarterbacks are
guys who can get focused and locked in
each and every week
and it's not easy to do but i think
tyler murray is also
that type of guy he's wired that way you
know i think he was raised that way with
his father
um and and i marvel because
steve kind the general manager as you
know rich
there was a lot of risk when he went out
and he fired steve wilkes
after after one season and decided that
okay we're going to make a change he
hires cliff kingsbury a lot of people
kind of were confused about that higher
and then on top of that after giving up
the 10th overall pick for josh rosen the
year before they decide to make kyler
murray the number one overall and
you say wow this this organization just
seems like they're kind of you know
treading water i mean where they go on
and
and it's worked out and uh kingsbury is
uh
done a really nice job offensively he's
changed some of his philosophy that's
been successful and
and then kyle murray's proved to be uh
you know worthy of the number one
overall pick and now they seem to be in
a good position to build and
continue to get better but i i like
their offensive personnel and like i
said i really like some of their young
players
they have on the defensive side of the
ball and uh that
that team is going to continue to you
know
in the music business it's a uh you know
they they're
whatever they're ranked with a bullet i
think they're i think they're rising you
know i really
do troy aikman pro football hall of
famer fox sports uh right here on the
rich eisen show
okay uh about a half an hour before we
go on the air where it hits it
sean payton's gonna go with taysom hill
that's who's his quarterback
i'm not surprised by that um because
when we talked to sean early in the
season they did sign tasem to a pretty
good contract coming into this year and
and
and taysom wants to play quarterback and
and the idea was
okay they're paying this money in the
event that something happens to drew
that he could
take over and when drew retires and so
what what sean had said to us was that
if
if drew brees went down in game like he
did
last week that jameis winston would be
the guy who would come in off the bench
because they have game plan for taysom
hill to be the swiss army knife and do
all his different things but then going
forward
if brees was going to miss games
multiple games that taste them would
be the guy because then they would gain
plan with him as the quarterback so
i i anticipated that would be
what they would do but you never know
until it's actually announced i mean
sean could have certainly changed his
mind because of all the things that
taysom hill can do so well
but i'm really excited about watching
him uh he
what a great competitor he is and uh and
he's tough as nails and
all the things that he can do this will
be a different looking offense as we
know
and and if anyone can make it work it'll
be sean who knows this player
exceptionally well
and uh it it's it's going to be fun i
think it's going to be fun for all of us
in the nfl to follow and it'll be fun
for the saints fans to watch so
what what's your best guess is he gonna
still run the
breezes plays with a little bit mixed in
of what he's done or they're just gonna
totally
go like um for the lack of a better
uh comparison like from flacco to lamar
like what the ravens did yeah
yeah no it's a good question and uh
i'll be honest i i i i would guess i
mean this is speculation i i think we're
gonna see
more of the the wild
cat if you will type offense maybe what
you see in in
in new england with with cam newton you
know they certainly have to be able to
take advantage
of his running ability uh relative to
what drew brees does as a runner
but don't underestimate how well he
throws the football either um
the first time we met uh first time
taysom hill was on this team this goes
back a couple years ago
i think we're doing a pre-season game
with new orleans we're talking to sean
payton and taysom hill's name comes up
i never heard the guy and he really
hadn't done anything yet they just got
them from green from green bay and
and sean's talking about him and and
what he said sean or what he said
rich was he said i'm not i'm not saying
we have
uh drew bree i mean i'm not saying we
have
steve young in the building but i feel
pretty good that we have our next
quarterback
uh walk in the halls here in new orleans
and so i mean he was sold on him i mean
shoot this guy
like holy cow who take some hell i mean
who's this guy
and he's been uh he's been a real
pleasure to watch i i
i haven't met taysom but i really love
the way he plays
and i think that he's going to not
surprise anybody in new orleans
but i think around the league who feel
that he's just kind of this gadget guy
who
gets the ball and runs and plays special
teams and all that
i think he's going to surprise a lot of
people and how he throws the football
troy
a few minutes left with the pro football
hall of famer i don't know if you've had
pittsburgh
yet this year but no so i so then i
asked in the caveat the best team you've
seen this year
with your own two eyes thursday night
sunday afternoons you know i will say
that uh
the best overall team that jumps to mind
right
now has been tampa bay um as far as
what they have or what they're capable
of being on offense and then how good
they they are on defense
i just haven't seen that kind of balance
but pittsburgh is there
because they play the they're obviously
when ben's upright
and healthy they're really good on
offense and then with their defense as
dominant as as they can be
um i i like them with uh with a healthy
drew brees i'll withhold judgment until
we see what they're able to do with take
them like we talked about
but yeah i and uh and i like
indianapolis but uh offensively can they
be explosive enough i think it's kind of
a question but that defense
you know it goes back to nick saban i i
it really jumped out of me a few weeks
ago when he said great defense is no
longer
beat great offenses and so
as great as indianapolis has been do
they have enough firepower
on offense um but i but i like that
group overall as well
yeah i know and you saw casey and the
kind of crazy
um you know reconfigured schedule
earlier in the year against buffalo um
you know and i do want to just pull on
that tampa strand a little bit here
because we had bruce aryans on on
tuesday and
basically said to him you know uh kurt
warner looks at the offense says
brady's clearly not comfortable in it
yet and would you agree with that
he said yes he agreed with it and i
asked well when do you think he's going
to get comfortable he joked but uh one
of those not really joking jokes of next
spring
is what he said yeah i think that's
probably right i i just don't know that
that they can get enough time on on task
at practice in order to have a
translator
there's been moments and and we've had
several tampa bay games already
tom's a friend i've had some pretty open
conversations with him
it's a different philosophy as far as
how he's reading things that's taken
a real adjustment for him he's used to
reading things short to deep
and and bruce arians reads everything
deep to short
and my experience as a quarterback is
it's dependent on
players whether you read it deep trying
to take a shot or whether you're coming
underneath
but it when when you're used to one
style and then you have to change it and
you've been doing it for twenty years
one way
it's been a big adjustment the thing i
noticed when i watched tom rich is that
you know here's a guy who rarely would
take sacks i mean he would unload the
football he always had an outlet on
where to go with the ball i saw him in
games where they couldn't block anybody
when he was at new england
and yet he would throw it away and then
when the play was there he'd make the
play
i i've never seen him get hit so much as
he's been hit in tampa
and the interceptions i mean that's just
and then you look back and you know
james winston all the interceptions that
he had last year you start to ask
yourself well
you know how much of it is the
quarterback how much of it is the way in
which they do things you know the high
risk no biscuit
type offense we hear bruce aaron's talk
about but i i agree i think
tom has handled everything remarkably
well in my opinion but
i don't think he's i don't he's really
comfortable
with everything yet either uh
but as we know they they are extremely
explosive and if he has games like
we've seen at times we had them against
the green bay packers they looked
terrific
uh other times it's not been quite so
good but if they can have those days
when they're playing well on offense
shoot they can play with anybody
last one for you troy i'd be remiss if i
didn't hit the cowboys with you who i
believe you're going to see on
thanksgiving right it's going to be you
and
joe okay against washington and alex
smith i mean that's
what a great story i'm sure you'll be
talking about that quite a bit pregame
and during the game
um but do you think jerry runs it back
with dak
we're knocking on wood he's gonna come
back healthy and mike mccarthy
like right now i know what it is right
now and the nfc east is still there but
do you think when it's all said and done
that that this is the this is the way
the cowboys are going to be constituted
not just for this year but beyond
what do you think yes um i don't think
there's any question they'll get dac
done
um dax price is going up each week um he
already had leverage and now he's going
to have even more leverage so
but i do think that jerry recognizes
just how valuable that prescott is i've
been saying it forever i mean the guy's
a great leader he's
he's made himself a great player from
when he came into the league and where
he was projected and what he was able to
do as a rookie
and and mike mccarthy uh i thought it
was a great hire when they made it
uh felt that he with his credentials and
resume was the right guy
this is a unique job and it's not always
easy you know there's a lot of
challenges
that a lot of people just aren't really
all that familiar with that i am having
been in the organization so
i think it takes the right kind of guy
and i feel that mike is that that guy
what happens though
rich is when you start having questions
what came out a few weeks ago when
players were
questioning the coaching and how uh
capable they were
i i that to me is hard to turn around
i mean it's hard then to have players
and buy
in if players who weren't buying in
right from the beginning and there's no
track record
uh here in dallas with mike even though
he's was successful in green bay
but with that being said there will not
be a change
at the end of this season regardless of
how this shapes up and
and we're all hopeful for get football
world towards all hopefully we get back
to a normal
life and are able to resume our normal
activities and if we're able to do that
then i think mike has a fighting chance
along with a lot of other coaches
uh in being able to to have a normal
offseason and go into the regular year
but
it's uh it it's been it's been kind of
something to watch from my perspective
for a team that i think
is talented they've had a number of
injuries but still have a lot of other
teams but they've just underperformed
you are the man troy appreciate the call
great call last night
have a good uh cast uh with uh with joe
on sunday and thanksgiving as well
you're you're awesome thanks for the
call
thank you rich appreciate you buddy
right back at you that's troy aikman pro
football hall of famer
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here